The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Alright.
So what we are doing
is covering 8.334,
which is statistical physics.
ANd let me remind you that
basically statistical physics
is a bridge from microscopic
to macroscopic perspectives.
And I'm going to emphasize a
lot on changing perspectives.
So at the level
of the micro, you
have the microstate that
is characterized, maybe,
by a collection of momenta
and coordinates of particles,
such as particles
of gas in this room.
Maybe those
particles have spins.
If you are absorbing
things on a surface,
you may have variables that
denote the occupation--
whether a particle or
site is occupied or not.
And when you're looking
at the microscopic world,
typically you are
interested in how
things change as a
function of time.
You have a kind of
dynamics that is governed
by some kind of a
[INAUDIBLE] which
is dependent on the microstate
that you are looking at,
and tells you about the
evolution of the microstate.
At the other extreme,
you look at the world
around you and the macro world.
You're dealing with
things that are described
by completely different things.
For example, if you're
thinking about the gas,
you have the pressure.
You have the volume.
So somehow, the
coordinates managed
to define and macrostate,
which is characterized
by a few parameters
in equilibrium.
If you have something like
a collection of spins,
maybe you will have
a magnetization.
And again, another
important thing
that characterizes
the equilibrium we
describe as temperature.
And when you're
looking at things
from the perspective of
macro systems in equilibrium,
then you have the
laws of thermodynamics
that govern constraints that
are placed on these variables.
So totally different
perspectives.
And what we have is that we
need to build a bridge from one
to the other and this
bridge is provided
by statistical mechanics.
And the way that we described
it in the previous course
is that to what you need is
a probabilistic prescription.
So rather than following
the time evolution
of all of these
degrees of freedom,
you'll have a
probability assigned
to the different
microstates that
are dependent on
the macro state.
And for example,
if you are dealing
in the canonical
ensemble, then you
know you're at the
particular temperature
this form has E to the
minus beta, this Hamiltonian
that we you have here
governing the dynamics.
Beta was one over KT.
So I could write
it in this fashion.
And the thing that
enabled us to make
a connection between this
deterministic perspective
and this equilibrium description
wire probabilities abilities
was relying on the limit
where the number of degrees
of freedom was very large.
And this very large number
of degrees of freedom
enabled us to, although we had
something that was probably
realistic, to really make very
precise statements about what
was happening.
Now, when we were doing
this program in 8-333,
we looked at very simple systems
that were essentially non
interacting, like the ideal gas.
Or we put a little bit
of weak perturbation
and by some manipulations,
we got things like liquids.
But the important thing is
that where is this program
we could carry out precisely
when we had no interactions.
In the presence
of interactions we
encountered, even in our
simplified perspective,
new things.
We went from the gas
state to a liquid state.
We didn't discuss
it, but we certainly
said a few things about solids.
And clearly there are much
more interesting things
that can happen when
you have interactions.
You could have other phases of
matter that we didn't discuss,
such as liquid crystals,
superconductors,
and many, many other things.
So the key idea is that you
can solve things that are not
interacting going
their own ways,
but when you put
interactions, you
get interesting
collective behaviors.
And what we want to do
in 8-334, as opposed
to just building the
machinery in 8-333,
is to think about all
of the different types
of collective behavior
that are possible
and how to describe them in
the realm of classical systems.
So we won't go much into the
realm of quantum systems, which
is also quite interesting as far
as its own collective behaviors
is concerned.
So that's the program.
Now, what I would
like to do is to go
to the description of the
organization of the class,
and hopefully this web
page will come back online.
So repeating what I was
saying before, the idea is
that interactions
give rise to a variety
of interesting
collective behaviors,
starting from pretty much
simple degrees of freedom
such as atoms and molecules
and adding a little bit
of interactions and
complexity to them,
you could get a variety of, for
example, liquid crystal phases.
But one of things to think about
is that you think about all
of the different atoms
and molecules that you
can put together, and the
different interactions that you
could put among them-- you
could even imagine things
that you construct in the lab
that didn't exist in nature--
and you put them together,
but the types of new behavior
that you encounter
is not that much.
At some level, you learn about
the three phases of matter,
gas, liquids, solids, of course,
as I said, there are many more,
but there are not
hundreds of them.
There are just a few.
So the question is why, given
the complexity of interactions
that you can have at
the microscopic scale,
you put things
together, and you really
don't get that many
variety of things
at the macroscopic level.
And the answer has to do with
mathematical consistency,
and has at its heart
something that you already
saw in 8-333, which is
the central limit theorem.
You take many random
variables of whatever ilk
and you add them
together, and the sum
has a nice simple
Gaussian distribution.
So somehow mathematics forces
things to become simplified
when you put many
of them together.
So the same thing
is happening when
you put lots of interacting
pieces together.
New collective behaviors
emerge, but because
of the simplification,
in the same sense
the type of simplification that
we see with the central limit
theorem, there aren't that
many consistent mathematical
descriptions that can emerge.
Of course, there
are nice new ones,
and the question is
how to describe them.
So this issue of what
are possible consistent
mathematical forms
is what we will
address through constructing
these statistical field
theories.
So one of the
important things that I
will try to impose upon you
is to change your perspective.
In the same way that there is
a big change of perspective
thinking about the microscopic
and macroscopic board,
there is also a change
of perspective involved
in the idea of starting from
interacting degrees of freedom,
and changing perspective
and constructing
a statistical future.
And I'll give you one
example of that today
that you're hopefully
all familiar with,
but it shows very much how this
change of perspective works,
and that's the
kind of metallurgy
that we will apply
in this course.
Basically the syllabus
is as follows.
So initially I will try
to emphasize to you how,
by looking at things,
by averaging over
many degrees of freedom, at long
lens scales and time scales,
you get simplified statistical
field theory descriptions.
The simplest one of
these that appears
in many different contexts
is this Landau-Ginzburg model
that will occupy us for
quite a few lectures.
Now once you construct
a description of one
of these statistical
field theories,
the question is how
do you solve it.
And there are a
number of approaches
that we will follow such as
mean field theory, et cetera.
And what we'll find is
that those descriptions
fail in certain dimensions.
And then to do
better than that, you
have to rely on things such
as perturbation theory.
So this is kind of
perturbation theory
that builds upon the types
of perturbation theory
that we did in the
previous semester, what
is closer to the kind
of perturbation theory
that you would be doing
in quantum field theories.
Alongside these
continuum theories,
I will also develop some lattice
models, that in certain limits,
are simpler and admit
either numerical approaches
or exact solutions.
The key idea that we
will try to learn about
is that of Kadanoff's
perspective of renormalization
group and how you
can, in some sense,
change your perspective
continuously
by looking at how a
system would look over
larger and larger
landscape, and how
the mathematical description
that you have for the system
changes as a function of
the scale of observation,
and hopefully becomes simple
at sufficiently large scales.
So we will conclude by looking
at a variety of applications
of the methodologies
that we have developed.
For example, in the context
of two dimensional films,
and potentially if we have
time, a number of other systems.
The first thing that I'm going--
the rest of the lecture today
has essentially nothing in
common with the material
that we will start to cover
as of the second lecture.
But it illustrates this
change in perspective
that is essential to
the way of thinking
about the material
in this course.
And the context that I will use
to introduce this perspective
is phonons and elasticity.
So you look around you,
there's a whole bunch
of different solids.
There's metals, there's
wood, et cetera.
And for each one
of them, you can
ask things about their
thermodynamic properties, heat
content, for example,
heat capacity.
They are constructed of various
very different materials.
And so let's try
to think, if you're
going to start
from this left side
from the microscopic
perspective,
how we would approach
the problem of the heat
content of these solids.
So you would say that solids,
if I were to go to 0 temperature
before I put any heat into them,
they would be perfect crystals.
What does that mean?
It means that if I look at
the positions of these atoms
or particles that are making
up the crystal-- I guess
I have to be more specific since
a metal is composed of nuclei
and electrons--
let's imagine that we
look at the positions
of the ions.
Then in the perfect
position they
will form a lattice where I
will pick three integers, L M
N and three unit
vectors, and I can
list the positions of all of
these ions in the crystal.
So this combination
L M N that indicates
the location of some particular
ion in the perfect solid
that's indicated by,
let's say, the vector r.
So this is the position that I
would have ideally for the ion
at zero temperature
that is labelled by r.
Now, of course when we go
to finite temperatures,
the particles, rather than
forming this nice lattice,
let's imagine a square
lattice in two dimension,
starts to move around.
And they're no longer going
to be perfect positions.
And these distortions we can
indicate by some vector u.
So when we have perfect
crystals across deformations,
this Q star changes
to a new position,
Q of r, which is it's ideal
position plus a distortion
field u, at each location.
OK?
Now associated with these
change of positions,
you have moved away from the
lowest energy configuration.
You have put energy
in the system.
And you would say that
the energy of the system
is going to be composed
of the following parts.
There's always going to be
some kind of a kinetic energy.
That's sum over r p
r squared over 2 m.
Let's imagine particles
all have the same mass m.
And then the reason
that these particles
form this perfect
crystal was presumably
because of the overlap
of electronic wave
functions, et cetera.
Eventually, if you're
looking at these coordinates,
there's some kind of
a many body potential
as a function of the positions
of all of these particles.
Now, what we are doing
is we are looking
at distortions that are small.
So let's imagine
that you haven't
gone to such high temperatures
where this crystal completely
melts and disappears and
gives us something else.
But we have small
changes from what
we had at zero temperature.
So presumably the
crystal corresponds
to the configuration that
gives us the minimum energy.
And then if I make a distortion
and expand this potential
in the distortion field, the
lowest order term proportional
to various u's will
disappear because I'm
expanding around the minimum.
And the first thing
that I will get
is from the second order term.
So I have one half sum over
the different positions.
I have to do the second
derivative of the potential
with respect to
these deformations.
Of course, if I am
in three dimensions,
I also have three spatial
indices, x, y, and z,
so I would have to take
derivatives with respect
to the different
coordinates, alpha and beta,
and summed over them.
And then I have u alpha
of r, u beta of r prime.
And then, of course, I will
have higher order terms
in this expansion.
This is a general potential,
so then in higher order terms,
it would be order of
u cubed and higher.
OK?
Fine?
So I have a system of this form.
Now, typically,
the next stage if I
stop at the quadratic
level-- this
I would do for a molecule
also, not only for a solid--
is to try to find the
normal modes of the system.
Normal modes I have to
obtain by diagonalizing
this matrix of
second derivatives.
Now, there are a few things
that I know that help me,
and one of the
things that I know
is that because the original
structure was a perfect solid,
let's say, then there
will be a matrix-- sorry,
there will be an element of
the second derivative that
corresponds to that
r and this r prime.
That's going to be the same
as the second derivative that
connects these two points,
because this pair of points
is obtained by the
first pair of points
by simple translation
among the lattice.
The environment for
this is exactly the same
as the environment for this.
So essentially, what I'm stating
is that this function does not
depend on r and r prime
separately, but only
on the difference
between r and r prime.
So, I know a lot--
so this is not
if I had n atoms
in my system, this
is not something like n squared
over 2 independent things,
it is a much lower number.
The fact that I have
such a lower number
allows me to calculate the
normal modes of the system
by Fourier transform.
I won't be very
precise about how
we perform Fourier transforms.
Basically I start with
this k alpha beta,
which is a function
of separation.
I can do a sum over all of
these separations r of e
to the i K dot r, for
appropriately chosen k.
And summing over all pairs of
differences, so the argument
r here now, is what was
previously r minus r prime.
So basically, what I can
do is I can pick one point
and go and look at all of the
separations from that point.
Construct this object, this will
give me the Fourier transformed
object that depends
on the vague number k.
So if I look at the
potential energy
of this system minus its value
at zero temperature, which
from one perspective was
one half sum over r r
prime alpha beta, is k alpha
beta, r minus r prime, u alpha
of r, u beta of r prime, in
the quadratic approximation.
If I do Fourier transforms
what happens because it is only
a function of r minus r
prime, and not r and r prime
separately, is that
in Fourier space,
it separates out into
a sum that depends only
on individual K modes.
There's no coupling
between k and k prime.
So here we have r and r prime,
but by the time we get here,
we just have one
k, alpha and beta.
We'll do one example of that
in more detail later on.
I have the Fourier
transformed object,
and then I have u alpha
k Fourier transform.
So in the same manner
that I Fourier transformed
this kernel, k alpha
beta, I can put here a u
and end up here with a U tilde
and u tilde beta of k star.
So we start over
here, if you like.
If I have n particles with
a matrix that is n by n--
actually 3n by 3n if I
account for the three
different orientations-- and
by going to Fourier transforms,
we have separated it out for
each of n potential Fourier
components, we just have
a three by three matrix.
And so then we can potentially
diagonalize this three
by three matrix to get two
eigenvalues, lambda alpha of K.
Once I have the
eigenvalues of the system,
then I can find frequencies
or eigenfrequencies.
Omega alpha of K,
which would be related
to this lambda alpha
of K divided by m.
So you go through
this entire process.
The idea was you start
with different solids.
You want to know what the
heat content of the solid is.
You have to make
various approximations
to even think about
the normal modes.
You can see that you
have to figure out
what this kernel
of the interaction
is-- Fourier transform it,
diagonalize it, et cetera
And ultimately thing that
you're after is that there are
these frequencies as a
function of wave number.
Actually, it's
really a wave vector,
because there will be three
different-- Kx, Ky and Kz.
And at each one
of these K values,
you will have three
eigenfrequencies.
And presumably as
you span K, you
will have a whole
bunch of lines that
will correspond to the
variations of these frequencies
as a function of K.
Why is that useful?
Well, the reason
that it's useful
is that as you go
to high temperature,
you put the energies into these
normal modes and frequencies.
That's why this whole
lattice is vibrating.
And the amount of
energy that you
have put at temperature
T on top of this V0
that you had at
zero temperature,
up to constants
of proportionality
that I don't want
to bother with is
a sum over all of these normal
modes that are characterized
by K and alpha, the polarization
and the wave vector.
And the amount of
energy, then, that you
would put in one harmonic
oscillator of frequency omega.
And that is something
that's we know
to be h bar omega alpha of
K, divided by e to the beta h
bar omega alpha of K minus 1.
So the temperature
dependence then
appears in this factor
of beta over here.
So the energy
content went there,
and if you want to,
for example, ultimately
calculate heat capacity,
I have to calculate
this whole quantity as a
function of temperature.
And then take the derivative.
So it seems like, OK, I have to
do this for every single solid,
whether it's copper,
aluminium, wood, or whatever.
I have to figure out what
these frequencies are,
what's the energy content
in each frequency.
And it seems like a complicated
engineering problem,
if you like.
Is that it about
this that transcends
having to look at all of these
details and come to this?
And of course, you know
the answer already,
which is that if I go to
sufficiently low temperature,
I know that the heat capacity
due to phonons for all solids
goes like t cubed.
So somehow, all of
this complexity,
if I go to low enough
temperature, disappears.
And some universal law emerges
that is completely independent
of all of these
details-- microscopics,
interactions, et cetera.
So our task-- this is the
change of perspective--
is to find a way to
circumvent all of these things
and get immediately to the heart
of the matter, the part that
is independent of the details.
Not that the details
are irrelevant.
Because after all, if you
want to give some material
that functions at some
particular set of temperatures,
you would need to know much
more than this t cubed law
that I'm telling you about.
But maybe from the
perspective of what
I was saying before-- how
many independent forms there
are, in the same sense that
adding up random variables
always gives you a Gaussian.
Of course, you don't know
where the mean and the variance
of the Gaussian is, but you are
sure that it's a Gaussian form.
So similarly, there is some
universality in the knowledge
that, no matter how
complicated the material is,
its low temperature heat
capacity is t cubed.
Can we get that by an approach
that circumvents the details?
So I'm going to do that.
But before, since I did a
little bit of hand-waving,
to be more precise, let's do
the one-dimensional example
in a little bit more detail.
So my one-dimensional
solid is going
to be a bunch of
ions or molecules
or whatever, whose
zero temperature
positions is uniformly separated
by some lattice spacing,
a, around one dimension.
And if I look at
the formations, I'm
going to indicate them by the
one-dimensional distortion
Un of the nth one
along this chain.
So then I would say, OK, the
potential energy of this system
minus whatever it is at zero,
just because of the distortion,
I will write as follows--
it is a sum over n.
And one thing that
I can do is to say
that if I look at two of these
things that are originally
at distance a, and then they
go and the deform by Un and Un
plus 1, the additional
deformation from a
is actually Un plus 1 minus Un.
So I can put some
kind of Hookean
elasticity and write
it in this fashion.
Now of course, there could be an
interaction that goes to second
neighbours.
So I can write that as
K2 over 2, Un plus 2,
minus Un squared and third
neighbors, and so forth.
I can add as many
of these as I like
to make it as
general as possible.
So in some sense, this is a
kind of rewriting of the form
that I had written over
here, where these things that
where a function
of the separation--
these K alpha beta of separation
or these K1, K2, K3, et
cetera-- in this series
that you would write down.
Now if you go to
Fourier space, what
you can do is each Un
of Un, is the distortion
in the original perspective,
you can Fourier transform.
And write it as a sum over K
e to the ik position the nth
particle is na,
times u tilde of k.
And once you make
this Fourier transform
in the expression over
here, you get an expression
for V minus V0 in terms
of the Fourier modes.
So rather than
having an expression
in terms of the amplitudes u
sub n, after Fourier transform,
I will have an expiration
in terms of u tilde of k.
So let's see what that is.
Forget about various
proportionality.
I have the sum over n.
Each one of the Un's I can
write in this fashion in terms
of U tilde of K. Since
this is a quadratic form,
I need to have two of these.
So I will have the
sum of k and k prime.
I have the factor of 1/2.
Each Un goes with a
factor of e to the i nak.
But then I had 2 Un.
There's a term here, if I do the
expansion, which is Un squared.
So I have one from k
and one from k prime.
However, if I have
Un plus 1 minus Un,
what I have is e
to the ika minus 1.
I already took the contribution
that was e to the ink.
From the second
factor, I will get e
to the ik prime a minus 1.
This multiplies K1 over 2.
And then I will have
something that's K2 over 2,
e to the 2ika minus 1, e to 2i
k prime a minus 1, and so forth.
Multiplying at the end
of the day U tilde of k,
U tilde of k prime.
Now when I do the sum over
n, and the only n dependence
appears over here,
then this is the thing
that forces k and k
prime to add up to 0,
because if they
don't add up to 0,
then I'm adding lots of
random phases together.
And the answer will be 0.
So essentially, this
sum will give me
a delta function that forces
k plus k prime to be 0.
And so then the additional
potential energy that you have
because of the distortion ends
up being proportional to 1/2,
sum over the different k's.
Only one k will
remain, because k prime
is forced to be minus k.
And so I have U of k,
U of minus k, which
is the same thing as U
of k complex conjugate.
So I will get that.
And then from here,
I will get K1.
Now then, k prime
is set to minus k.
And when I multiply
these two factors,
I will get 1 plus 1
minus e to the ika minus
e to the minus ika.
So I will get 2
minus 2 cosine of ka.
And then I will have K2, 2 minus
cosine of 2ka, and so forth.
Why are the lights not on?
OK, still visible.
So yes?
AUDIENCE: So in your last slide,
you have an absolute value Uk,
but wouldn't it
be-- right above it,
is it U of k times U star of k
prime, or how does that work?
PROFESSOR: OK, so
the way that I have
written is each
Un I have written
in terms of U tilde of k.
And at this first stage, the two
factors of Un that I have here,
I treat them completely
equivalently with indices k
and k prime.
So there is no complex
conjugation involved here.
But when k prime is
set to be minus k,
then I additionally realize that
if I Fourier transform here,
I will find that
U tilde of minus k
is the same thing as
U tilde of k star.
Because essentially, the complex
conjugation appears over here.
It's not that important a point.
The important point
is that we now
have an expression
for our frequencies,
or omega alpha of k-- actually,
there's no polarization.
It's just omega
of k-- are related
to square root of something
like a mass down here.
Again, that's not
particularly important,
but something like k1, 2
minus 2 cosine of ka, k2, 2
minus 2 cosine of
2ka, and so forth.
So I can plot these frequencies
omega as a function of k.
One thing to note
is first of all,
the expression is
clearly symmetric under k
goes to minus k, so it only
depends on cosine of k.
So it is sufficient
to draw one side.
The other side for negative
k would be the opposite.
The other thing to
note is that again,
if I do this Fourier
transformation,
and I have things
that are spaced by a,
it effectively means that
the shortest wavelength
that I have to deal with
are of the order of k, which
means that the wave numbers
are also kind of limited
by something that
I can't go beyond.
So there's something that in
the generalized over here,
you recall that your k vectors
are within the Brillouin zone.
In one dimension, the Brillouin
zone is simply between minus 5
over a and 5 over a.
Now the interesting thing to
note is that as k goes to 0,
omega goes to 0.
Because all of these factors
you can see, as k goes to 0,
vanish.
In particular, if I
start expanding around k
close to zero, what I find
is that all of these things
are quadratic.
They go like k squared.
So when I take the
square root, they
will have an
absolute value of k.
So I know for sure that
these omegas start with that.
What I don't know, since
I have no idea what k1,
k2, et cetera are, is
what they do out here.
So there could be some
kind of a strange spaghetti
or going on over
here, I have no idea.
There's all kinds of complexity.
But they are away from
the k close to 0 part.
Again, why does it go 0?
Of course, k equals
to 0 corresponds
to taking the entire
chain and translating it.
And clearly, I
constructed this such
that all of the U's
are the same-- I
take everything and translate
it-- there's no energy cost.
So there's no energy
costs for k equals to 0.
The energy costs for
small k have to be small.
By symmetry, they have
to be quadratic in case,
so I take the square root
and we will get a linear.
Of course, you know
that this linear part--
we can say that omega is
something like a sum velocity.
So all of these
chains, when I go
to low enough case or
low enough frequencies,
admit these sound-like waves.
Now heat content-- what
am I supposed to do?
I'm supposed to take
these frequencies,
put them in the expression
that I have over here,
and calculate what's going on.
So again, if I want to look at
the entirety of everything that
is going on here, I
would need to know
the details of k2,
k3, k4, et cetera.
And I don't know all of that.
So you would say
I haven't really
found anything universal yet.
But if I look at one
of these functions,
and plot it as a function of
the frequency, what do I see?
Well, omega goes to 0.
I can expand this.
What I get is kt.
Essentially, it's a statement
that low frequencies
behave like classical
oscillators.
A classic oscillator
has an energy kt.
Once I get to a
frequency that is
of the order of kt
over h bar, then
because of the exponential,
I kind of drop down to 0.
So very approximately,
I can imagine
that this is a function
that is kind of like a step.
It is either 1 or 0.
And the change
from 1 to 0 occurs
at the frequency that is related
to temperatures by k2 over a.
So if I'm at some high
temperature, up here,
and I want to-- so this omega
is k v t sum i over h bar--
that's the corresponding
high frequency--
I need to know all
of these frequencies
to know what's going on
for the energy content.
But if I go to lower
and lower temperatures,
eventually I will get to
low enough temperatures
where the only thing that I
will see is this linear portion.
And I'm guaranteed
that I will see that.
I know that I will
see that eventually.
And therefore, I
know that eventually,
if I go to low
enough temperatures,
the excitation energy
becomes low enough,
it's simply proportional
to this integral from 0.
I can change the upper part
of the infinity if I like.
dk h bar 1k divided by e to
the beta h bar dk minus 1,
And again, dimensionally, I
have two factors of k here.
Each k scales with kt.
So I know that whole thing is
proportional to kt squared.
In fact, there's some
proportionality constants
that depend on h
bar, t, et cetera.
It doesn't matter.
The point is this t squared.
So I know immediately
that my heat capacity
is proportional to--
derivative of this
is going to be
proportional to t.
The heat capacity of a
linear chain independent
of what you do.
So no matter what the
state of interactions
is, if I start with a situation
such as this at 0 temperature,
I know if I put energy into
it at low enough temperature,
I would get this heat
capacity that is linear.
I don't know how
low I have to do.
Because how I have
to go to depends
on what this velocity is, what
the other complication is,
et cetera.
So that's the part
that I don't know.
I know for sure of
the functional form,
but I don't know the amplitude
of that functional form.
So the question is, can
we somehow get this answer
in a slightly different
way, without going
through all of these things?
And the idea is to
do a coarse grain.
So what's going on here?
Why is it that I got is form?
Well, the reason I
got this form was I
got to low enough temperature.
At low enough temperature,
I have only the possibility
of exciting emote, whose
frequencies were small.
I find that frequencies small
correspond to wave numbers
k that are small,
or they correspond
to wavelengths that
are very large.
So essentially, if
you have you solid,
you go to low
enough temperature,
you will be exciting modes of
some characteristic wavelength
that are inversely
proportional to temperature,
and become larger and larger.
So eventually, these
long wavelength modes
will encompass whole
bunches of your atoms.
So this lambda
becomes much larger
than the spacing of the
particles in the chain
that you were looking at.
And what you're looking
at. low temperature,
is a collective behavior that
encompasses lots of particles
moving collectively
and together.
And again, because of
some kind of averaging
that is going on over
here, you don't really
care about the interactions
among small particles.
So it's the same idea.
It's the same large
n limit appearing
in a different context.
It's not the n that
becomes very large,
but n that becomes of the order
of, let's say, 100 lattice
spacings-- already much larger
than an individual atom doing
something, because it's
a collection of atoms
that are moving together.
So what I drew here was
an example of a mode.
But I can imagine
that I have some kind
of a distortion in my system.
Now, I started with
the distortions Un
that were defined at the
level of each individual atom,
or molecule, or variable
that I have over here.
But I know that things
that are next to each other
are more or less
moving together.
So what I can do
is I can average.
I can sort of pick
aa distance-- let's
call it the x-- and average
of all of those Un's that
are within that distance
and find how that averages.
And as I move my interval
that I'm averaging,
I'm constructing this
core function U of x.
So there is a moving window
along the chain constructed
with the Vx which is
much larger than a,
but is much less than this
characteristic frequency.
And using that, I can
construct a distortion field.
I started discrete variables.
And I ended up with a
continuous function.
So this is an example
of a statistical field.
So this distortion appears
to be defined continuously.
But in fact, it has much
less degrees of freedom,
if you like, compared to all of
the discrete variables that I
started with.
Because this continuous
function certainly
does not have, when
I fully transform it,
variations at short
length scales.
So we are going
to be constructing
a lot of these coarse
grained statistical fields.
If you think about the
temperature in this room,
bearing from one location to
another location pressure,
so that we don't strike
sound waves, et cetera.
All of these things are
examples of a continuous field.
But clearly, that
continuous field
comes from averaging things that
exist at the microscopic level.
So it's kind of
counter-intuitive
that I start with
discrete variables,
and I can replace them with
some continuous function.
But again, the emphasis is
that this continuous function
has a limited set of
available and surveyed numbers
over which it is defined.
OK.
So we are going to describe
the system in terms of this.
So that analog of this
potential that we have over here
is some b function
of this U of x.
And I want to construct
that function.
And so the next step
after you decided
what your statistical
field is to construct
some relevant thing, such
as an potential energy that
is appropriate with
that statistical field,
putting as limited amount
of information as possible
in construction of that.
So what are the
things that we are
going to put in constructing
this function at.
The first thing
that I will do is
I will assume that there
is a kind of locality.
By which, I mean the following.
While this is in
principle the function
of the entire function,
locality means
that I will write it as an
integral of some density, where
the density at location
x that I'm integrating
depends on you at that location.
But not just you, also
including derivatives of you.
And you can see
that this is really
a continuum version of what
I have written here, this.
If I go to the continuum,
this goes like a derivative.
And if I look at further
and further distances,
I can construct higher
and higher derivatives.
So in the sense that this is
a quite general description,
I can construct any kind
of potential in here
by choosing interactions.
K1, K2, K3, K100 that go
further and further apart,
you would say that if I include
sufficiently high derivatives
here, I can also
include interactions
that are extending over
far away distances.
The idea of locality is that
while you make this expansion,
our hope is that at
the end of the day,
we can terminate this
expansion without needing
to go to many,
many higher orders.
So locality is two parts.
One, that you will
write it in this form.
And secondly, that
this function will not
depend on many, many
high derivatives.
The second part of
it is symmetries.
Now, one of the things
that I constructed in here
and ultimately was very relevant
to the result that I had
was that if I take
a distortion U
of x and I add a
constant to everybody,
so if I replace all of my Uns
to plus Un plus 5, for example,
the energy does not change.
So V of this is the same
thing as V of U of x.
So that's a symmetry.
Essentially, it's this
translation of symmetry
that I was saying right
here at the beginning,
that this only depends on
the separation of two points.
It's the same thing.
But what that means is that
when you write your density
function, then the density
cannot depend on U of x.
Because that would violate this.
So you can only be
start with things
that depend on the U of V
IBX this second, et cetera.
So this is 1.
This is 2.
Another thing is what
I call stability.
You are looking at distortions
around a state that corresponds
to being a stable
configuration of your system.
What that means is that you
cannot have any pairs in this
expansion that are linear.
So again, this was
implicit in everything
that we did over here.
We went to second order.
But there's third order, et
cetera, are not ruled out.
It is more than that.
Because you require the second
order terms to have the right
sign, so that your
system corresponds
to being at the bottom
of a quadratic potential
rather than the top of it.
So there is a bit more than
the absence of linear terms.
So given that, you would
say that your potential
for this system as a function
now of this distortion
is something like
an integral over x.
And the first thing that is
consistent with everything
we have written so
far is that if we
be proportional to
du by dx squared.
So there's a coefficient
that I can put here.
Let's call it k over 2.
It cannot depend on you.
It has to be quadratic
function of derivative.
That's the first thing
I can write down.
I can certainly write
down something like d2u
by dx to the fourth power.
And if I consider higher
order terms, why not something
like the second
derivative squared,
first derivative squared, a
whole bunch of other things.
So again, there's still
many, many, many terms
that I can't write down.
Yes?
Is that second
term supposed to be
a second derivative
to the fourth power?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Thank you.
So that when I fully
transform this,
the quadratic part becomes
sum over k, k over 2.
This fully transformed,
becomes k squared.
as you said,
is second derivative squared.
So it becomes k to the fourth.
I have a whole bunch of terms.
And then I have U of k squared.
And then I will have higher
order terms from Fourier
fully transform of this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does this actually
forbid odd derivatives?
Are you saying the third
derivative and stuff don't--
PROFESSOR: I didn't go into
that, because that depends
on some additional
considerations,
whether or not you
have a mirror symmetry.
If you have a mirror symmetry,
you cannot have terms of that
are odd and x.
Whether or not you have some
condition on U and minus U may
or may not forbid third order
terms in [? U ?] [? by  the ?]
x.
So once I go beyond
the quadratic level,
I need to rely on some
additional symmetry statement
as to which additional terms
I am allowed to write down.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Also the coefficients
could depend on x, right?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So one of the things
that I assumed
was this symmetry, which
means that every position
in the crystal is the same
as any other position.
So here, if I break and
make the coefficient
to be different from here,
different from there,
it amounts to the same thing,
that the starting point was not
the crystal.
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't
that be written
as-- in the place where you
wrote down the symmetry,
it should be U of x plus
c inside the parenthesis?
PROFESSOR: No.
No.
So look at this.
So if I take Un and I
replace Un to Un plus 5,
essentially I take
the entire lattice
and move it by a distance.
Actually, 5 was
probably not good.
5.14.
It's not just anything
I can put over here.
Energy will not change.
OK?
AUDIENCE: That must be
different from adding
to all the ends a
constant displacement.
PROFESSOR: Ends are
labels of your variables.
So I don't know what mean by--
AUDIENCE: OK, you're right.
But in that picture, where
instead of N's, we have X?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It seems like
displacing in space
would mean adding up to x.
PROFESSOR: No.
No.
It is this displacement.
I take U1, U2, U3, U4.
U1 becomes U1 plus .3.
U2 becomes U2 plus .3.
Everybody moves in step.
AUDIENCE: So the conclusion
is the coefficients
don't depend on x?
PROFESSOR: If you have a
system that is uniform--
so this statement here
actually depends on uniformity.
This is an additional
thing, uniform.
So one part of the
material is the same.
Now, you have
non-uniform systems.
So you take your crystal
and you bombard it
with neutrons or whatever.
Then you have defects
all over the place.
Then one location
will be different
from another location.
You are not able to
write that anymore.
So uniformity is
another symmetry
that I kind of implicitly used.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When your
uniform is a separate part,
why isn't it implied by
translational symmetry?
PROFESSOR: If I take this
material that I neutron
bombarded, and I
translate it in space,
it's internal energy will
still not change, right?
AUDIENCE: OK.
OK.
PROFESSOR: So again, once
I come to this stage,
what it amounts to is
that I have constructed
a kind of energy as a function
of a deformation field, which
in the limit of very
long wavelengths
has this very simple form
which is the integral du by dx
squared.
There are higher order terms.
But hopefully in the
limit of long wavelengths,
the higher derivatives
will disappear.
In the limit of
small deformation,
the higher order
terms will disappear.
So the lowest order term
at long wavelengths,
et cetera, is
parametrized by this 1k.
If I fully transport it, I will
just get k over 2k squared.
When I take the frequency
that corresponds to that,
I will get that
kind of behavior.
So by kind of relying on
these kinds of statements
about symmetry, et cetera,
I was able to guess that.
Now, let's go and do
with this for the case
of material in three dimensions.
Actually, in any dimensions,
in higher dimensions.
So I take a solid
in three dimensions,
or maybe a film in 2 dimensions.
I can still describe
it's deformations
at low enough temperature in
terms of long wavelength modes.
I do the coarse graining.
I have U of x.
Actually, both U and
x are now vectors.
And what I want to
do is to construct
a potential that
corresponds to this end.
OK?
So I will use the
idea of locality.
And I write it as an integral
over however many dimensions
I have.
So d is the
dimensionality of space
of some kind of
an energy density.
And the energy density now
will depend on U. Actually,
U has many components,
U alpha of x.
Derivatives of U-- so I will
have du alpha by dx beta.
And you can see that
higher order derivatives,
they're really more
and more indices.
So the complication
now is that I
have additional
indices involved.
The symmetry that I will use
is a slightly more complicated
version of what I had before.
I will take the
crystal, U of x, and I
can translate it
just as I did before.
And I just say that this
translation of crystal
does not change its energy.
But you know something else?
I can take my crystal,
and I can rotate it.
The internal energy
should not change.
So there is a rotation
of this that also you
can put the c inside of.
Before or after rotation,
it doesn't matter.
The energy should
not depend on that.
OK.
So let's see what we
have to construct.
I can write down the answer.
So first of all, we know
immediately that the energy
cannot depend on U itself for
the same reason as before.
It can depend on derivatives.
But this rotation
and derivatives
is a little bit strange.
So I'm going to use a trick.
If I do this in Fourier
space, like I did over here,
I went from this to
k over 2 integral dk
k squared U tilde of k squared.
If I stick with sufficiently
low derivatives,
only at the level of the
second order derivatives,
if I have a second order form
that depends on something
like this, I can still
go to Fourier space.
And the answer will be of
the form integral d dk.
The different k modes will only
get coupled from higher order
terms, third order
terms, et cetera.
At the level of
quadratic, I know
that the answer is
proportional to d dk.
And for all of the reasons that
we have been discussing so far,
the answer is going
to be U of k squared
times some function of k, like
k squared, k to the fourth.
Now, whatever I
put over here has
to be invariant under rotations.
So, let's see.
I know that the answer
that I write here
should be quadratic
[INAUDIBLE] tilde.
It should be at
least quadratic in k,
because I'm looking
at derivatives.
In the same way
that I had k here,
I should have factors of k here.
But k is a vector when I
go to three dimensions.
U becomes a vector when
I go to three dimensions.
So I want to construct
something that
involves quadratic in vector
k, quadratic in vector U,
and is also invariant
under rotations.
One thing that I
know is that if I
do a dot product of two
vectors, that dot product
is invariant on the rotations.
So I have two vectors.
So I know, therefore,
that k squared,
k dot k is a
rotational invariant.
The tilde of k squared is
rotationally invariant.
But also, k dot U
tilde of k squared
is rotationally invariant.
OK?
So what I can do is I can say
that the most general form
that I will write down
will allow 2 terms.
The coefficients of that
are traditionally called mu.
This is mu over 2.
This one is called mu
plus lambda over 2.
Actually, I have to put an
absolute value squared here.
So that's the most
general theory
of elasticity in any
number of dimensions
that is consistent with this
symmetry that I have here.
And it turns out
that this corresponds
to elasticity of materials
that are isotropic.
And they are described by
2 elastic coefficients,
mu and lambda, that are called
[INAUDIBLE] coefficient.
Mu is also related
to shear modules.
Actually, mu and lambda combined
are related to [INAUDIBLE]
And if I want, in fact,
to fully transform
this back to the space, in
real space the can be written
as mu over 2 mu alpha
beta of x mu alpha
beta over x, where the sum over
alpha and beta takes place.
Alpha and beta run from 1 to d.
And the other term,
lambda over 2,
is U alpha alpha of
x, U beta beta of x.
And this object, U
alpha beta, is one half
of the symmeterized derivatives,
du alpha by dx beta plus du
beta by dx alpha.
And it's called the strength
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So are
you still looking
in the regime of low
energy expectations?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: So wouldn't
the discreteness
of the allowed wave
vectors become important?
And if so, why are
you integrating
rather than discrete summon?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's go back to
what we have over here.
The discreteness is
present over here.
And what I am looking at for
the discreteness, this spacing
that I have between these
objects is 2pi over L.
The L is the size of the system.
So if you like, what
we are looking at here
is the hierarchy of
landscapes, where
L is much larger than
the typical wavelengths
of these excitations that are
set by the temperature, which
is turn much larger
than the lattice place.
And so when we are
talking about, say,
a solid at around 100
degrees temperature or so,
this-- then say, over
here, it typically spans
10 to 100 atoms, where as
the actual size of the system
spans billions of atoms or more.
And so the separations
that are imposed
by the discreteness
of k are irrelevant
to the considerations
that we have.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So before, with
this adding a constant c, that
corresponds to translating
almost crystal by some vector.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: For the rotation, is
this a rotation of the crystal
or is this a rotation of
the displacement field?
PROFESSOR: It's the rotation
of the entire crystal.
So you can see that
essentially both x and U
have to be rotated together.
I didn't write it
precisely enough.
But when I wrote the
invariant as being k dot U,
the implicit thing was
that the debate vector
and the distortion are rotated.
AUDIENCE: So does it require an
isotropic crystal in that case?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I would
think if you're
rotating everything
together, who
cares if one axis is
different than another?
Because if I have a
non-isotropic crystal
and I rotate it
around, it shouldn't
change the internal energy.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Where it will make difference
is at higher order terms.
And so then I have to think
about the invariants that
are possible at the level
of higher order terms.
But that's a good question.
Let me come back and try answer
that more carefully next time
around.